qu'il est loin le bhoutan les français
se précipiter sur les vendeurs de
journaux vendus l'an et où les parisiens
se pressaient dans les kiosques
aujourd'hui la presse ne va pas fort et
c'est peu dire si une presse qui
arrêtent pas de faire des plans de
départs volontaires et qui voient se
réduire d'année en année le nombre de
journalistes qui travaillent pour elle
donc qu on regarde la diffusion qu'on
regarde la recette publicitaire on
regarde comme l'indicateur le plus
parlant d'après moi de la qualité d'un
média le nombre de journalistes qui est
qu'ils travaillent dans tous les cas on
peut dire que c'est une presse qui est
vraiment en crise aujourd'hui
mais tout n'est pas perdu regardez bien
ces visages ils ne sont pas à la une des
médias mais derrière eux ont fait le
pari d'une autre presse presse papier
oppressant ligne ils y croient nous les
avons rencontrés prenons par exemple les
dirigeants de son presse un peu plus
décontracté gamine sans qu'il ait l'air
ridicule
franck annese le fondateur formé en
école de commerce est passé par la pub à
d'abord lancé il y à 12 ans so foot
gros succès suivi de magazines sur le
cinéma les enfants ou le vélo le pari
avec leur petit dernier society 3 euros
90 en kiosque que tous les quinze jours
sera de se faire une place sur le marché
des grands hebdo généralistes on avait
envie de montrer qu'on peut lancer des
magazines aujourd'hui faire des
magazines qui marche on a une logique de
éditorial aussi quitterait sur
l'exigence sur le fait que nous le
lecteur il essayait pour le tour nous le
lecteur c'est quasiment un ambassadeur
du magazine c'est à dire que quand c'est
construit so foot au départ on vendait
pas grand chose ça c'est on n'a jamais
lancé des magazines qui vendait beaucoup
puis qu'après ce casser la gueule en
fait nous on lance des magazines qui
vendent et puis qui peu à peu en un peu
plus et ainsi de suite
et le lecteur en fait un lecteur
engendre trois lecteurs puis trois
lecteurs engendre 9 lecteurs rien
société lapacho presse c'est une
écriture jeunes quelques scoops et une
communauté de lecteurs fans le groupe de
presse est passé de 10 à 45 salariés
avec une bonne partie des journalistes
qui ont grandi dans l'esprit du groupe
loin on a toujours parlé du foot à
travers un prisme culturel politique de
société donc aux bulls finalement
society s'était juste élargir le prise
mais
et avoir un champ beaucoup plus
important puis on vieillit donc certains
s'intéressent moins au foot on qu'ils
ont peut-être envie d'écrire sur des
sujets entre guillemets plus nobles
comme la politique la culture
là on va pas se manger passé de séné
ronaldo alain juppé ça ne change pas
mais pour démarrer soucy qui a quand
même mis beaucoup d'argent
un million et demi d'euros partagés
entre un prêt bancaire et des
actionnaires inattendus comme un ex
président du psg
deux anciens footballeurs professionnels
ou un producteur de canal+ dirigions
nous maintenant vers le 6e
arrondissement de paris au coeur du
quartier de l'édition c'est ici que se
fabriquent la revue 21
lancé il ya sept ans par un éditeur et
un journaliste patrick de saint-exupéry
le 21
c'est ce qu'on appelle un mook
contraction linguistique de magazines et
de bouc qu'on a constatée ces dernières
années ça avant de la presse vers
l'actualité ce qui est parfaitement
logique a les moyens de communication
sont développés et la presse est rentré
de plus en plus dans le rythme de
l'actualité et en même temps ça crée un
déséquilibre il actualité manque de
recul parfois et donc la proposition de
le de 21 qui est une revue trimestrielle
distribué en librairie avec du travail
sur le récit en profondeur est une
proposition qui vise à rééquilibrer un
peu ce champ de la presse ou la
dominante était très actualité et ses
ramené de 2 de la profondeur en plus de
l'actualité les deux sont tout à fait
légitimes et c'est un réquilibrage en
fait la proposition de la presse
générale changer le tempo de
l'information les inventeurs de la revue
avait formalisé leur utopie dans un
manifeste pour un autre journalisme
édité à presque cinquante mille
exemplaires
la revue 21 avec sept journalistes tire
ses revenus uniquement de ses ventes
en quelques années les mook vendus
souvent aux alentours de 15 euros se
sont multipliés utilisant les circuits
de distribution du livre l'une de ces
revues trimestriels la revue des six
et réussi à s'imposer en traitant de
l'actualité entièrement en dessin franck
bourgeron et david servenay lawful des
il y a deux ans ouais je vois par
exemple le grand personnage au milieu
oui si tu vois si les bars
moi je me disais au moins lui parce que
tu veux le comprends que c'est le maire
parce qu'il assure des chats mais
peut-être qu'on peut faire anne simon a
suivi la campagne des municipales à
bobigny l'année dernière avec une
journaliste elle est illustratrice et
auteur de bd
ce jour là elle est venue présenter son
récit en images aux deux rédacteurs en
chef
on va en plus à bobigny voilà c'est la
banlieue il ya il ya une architecture
particulière quand on va dans une mairie
les bureaux enfin vraiment une personne
qui parle en fait ça peut se ressentir
dans un dessin aussi je vais regarder
ses mimiques la fin voilà il peut avoir
des tic
voilà donc tous et tout ça ça me donne
des idées de mise en page et voilà pour
rendre la bande dessinée plus vivante
la bande dessinée c'est un art qui est
assez long à exécuter et aujourd'hui le
temps c'est ce qui manque dans notre pas
devant tout cas beaucoup au journalisme
c'est à dire que on est avec l'arrivée
du numérique internet
abreuvés au quotidien énormément
d'informations mais l'ensemble de ces
informations fait plus forcément sens et
dans la revue dessinée c'est exactement
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
retrouver de redonner du sens à
l'information
donc c'est pour ça qu'on privilégie
particulièrement les gens de l'enquète
du reportage mais on s'attache à ce que
ça soit journalistique man le plus
possible validé vérifier à chaque fois
un tandem journaliste dessinateur
s'empare d'un sujet bien souvent une
enquête approfondie comme sur les
migrants aux frontières de l'europe
les emprunts toxiques ou encore l'
affaire des biens mal acquis et les
relations entre la france et l'afrique
là ce qui est extraordinaire avec la
bande dessinée c'est qu'évidemment peut
pas être partout et on a très peu
d'image parce qu'évidemment les gens qui
sont mis en cause
refuse de parler ou éventuellement peut
avoir leur avocat mais c'est quand même
pas très excitant et là avec la bande
dessinée on peut reconstituer tout un
tas d'événements
que ce soit je sais bien la saisie du
patrimoine immobilier de teodoro obiang
guema donc le président de guinée le
fils du président de la guinée
équatoriale carey train de vie
absolument démentielle ça c'est une
relation saine qui correspond et bien à
la saisie de des voitures de teodoro
obiang guema avenue foch personne
n'était présent voilà maintenant
reconstitue l'ensemble de la scène et la
réaction absolument furieuse de théodore
un organe équatoriale et qui appelle
immédiatement les disait pour se
plaindre de ces méthodes partie avec 180
mille euros de capital
les fondateurs sont aussi actionnaire
majoritaire avec dix sept mille
exemplaires et sans publicité
la revue dessinée est d'ores et déjà une
réussite un autre homme a aussi voulu du
changement eric fottorino connu et
reconnu
il fut successivement journaliste puis
rédacteur en chef pour finir directeur
du quotidien le monde
avant de le quitter il ya sept ans sur
le projet du fn
insatiable le travailleur est amoureux
de l'information il lance l'année
dernière avec laurent kramer lui aussi
ancien directeur au monde
le11 hebdomadaire qui se déplie façon
poster sur papier recyclé de 90 grammes
dans ce but il ya déjà quasiment une
année de 2 1 de cette feuille pliée
je vais vous montrer quelques quelques
exemples
on a traité comme ça au mois de février
à un sujet sur les les mouvements
djihadistes en afrique et donc on a
comme ca réalisé une grande carte qu'on
retrouve souvent à fils affiché au
nombre des d'écoles dans des fan est
souvent le fait que le format soit drive
permet justement de mieux se rendre
compte des réalités des situations de
leur complexité
car le fond aussi se veut différent un
sujet d'actualité unique abordé par
différents contributeurs
dès lors qu'on convoque plusieurs
regards
plusieurs spécialistes plusieurs types
de spécialistes quand vous allez voir un
anthropologue un économiste sociologue
forcément ils n'ont pas le même regard
sur le sujet que vous traitez 25000
exemplaires pour un journal vendu 2
euros 80 l'équilibré financier n'est pas
encore atteint mais heureusement pour le
1-1 riches donateurs financent en partie
le journal l'argent justement c'est la
spécialité de julia cagé l'économiste
des médias pour l argent et qualité sont
étroitement liées force que la première
chose c'est vraiment que pour produire
une information de qualité faute des
journalistes
il faut donner aux journalistes les
moyens l'argent et le temps de l'enquète
le temps de l'investigation le temps du
reportage si on prend toutes les grandes
enquêtes dans les années dans les années
récentes en fait qui ont abouti sur des
révélations des scandales d'état et ses
traces et des enquêtes qui ont été
longues
c'est des enquêtes qui ont été coûteuses
et si vous demandez juste un journaliste
d'écrire un article par jour de publier
en ligne de mettre google +2 le tweet
est d'en faire sa pub sur internet
dans ce cas-là ce journaliste là aussi
bons qu'ils soient aussi doué qui soit
aussi bien informés qu'ils soient en
fait il va pas pouvoir fournir un papier
de qualité table
mais c'est une maternité militaire dès
le départ oui un stylo un cahier un
smartphone du reportage à moindre coût
il n'empêche cécile dubois est sur tous
les fronts de l'actualité du val de
marne
ce jour là une manifestation contre la
fermeture annoncée de la maternité de
l'hôpital bégin la rédaction 94 ou
poignants mauvaise mais confortable 94
citoyens un site internet gratuit
d'information locale et indépendant qui
fonctionne adossé à une petite société
familiale
le premier principe c'est d'être d'avoir
un modèle économique très sobre une
partie de nos ressources repose sur des
prestations de services informatiques de
services web qui sont attirés assurée
par une partie de l'entreprise
et puis la rédaction on a également
comme ressource la publicité c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment avoir un
commercial et c'est pas facile de de
trouver un commercial qui nous régit qui
s'intéresse à des petits titres malgré
une audience non négligeable deux cent
mille visiteurs uniques par mois une
formule payante ne serait pas viable
pour 94 citoyens mais le modèle d'une
information payante ans à devenir
dominants sur la toile c'est ce qu'ont
choisi laurent mauriac et damien
cirotteau anciens de libération et de
rue89
en janvier dernier ils ont lancé brief
mis une lettre d'information envoyée par
mail tous les jours pour 5 euros 90 par
mois
et tout ça sans publicité par rapport au
financement évidemment nous rencontrons
compte sur les abonnements pour eux pour
nous financer
on a un vestiaire londonien petit peu
d'argent on a ce qu'on a investi
récolter un peu d'argent lors de la copa
de cross fading pour l'instant ça me
suffit si après il faut il faut
accélérer où on a besoin d'un
financement autres on y recourt à mais
pour l'instant c'est pas la stratégie
le crowdfunding c'est un système de dons
via une plateforme internet 22000 euros
ont ainsi été récoltés soit la moitié du
capital de départ et près de 900 près
abonnement la rédaction réduite à deux
ou trois personnes travaillent surtout à
partir de l'info créés par d'autres moi
j'ai vu un une déclaration à ses formes
d'obama nous notre travail c'est de dans
toute cette masse d'informations c'est
un peu de se mettre à la place du
lecteur et puis de se dire quels sont
les sujets qui sont les plus des plus
pertinents et plus intéressants qui sont
pas simplement anecdotique parce que ça
on en voit beaucoup sur le web notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux donc il faut
surtout pas s'arrêter à ça et donc
choisir des sujets qui qui qui attire
l'attention mais qui en même temps soit
pertinent et du sens et une vraie portée
et soit pas simplement des choses un peu
futiles ou un peu légère
briffe me projette maintenant une
application smartphone de sa lettre
d'information
car si les supports se diversifient la
consommation d'information évolue elle
aussi ordinateurs téléphones tablettes
selon la dernière étude où dix presse
chez les moins de 35 ans la lecture de
la presse sur mobile est même désormais
supérieure à celle sur l'internet fixe